je reprends quelques principes généraux
également
peut-être parce qu'il est bon d'insister
dessus ça faisait partie justement des
des conclusions dont
David Lisnard
parlait c'est un vrai sujet de cohésion
nationale cette affaire de loi
plus on en met dans la loi finalement
moins elle est respectée parce que si on
peut beaucoup déroger et moi et plus on
s'écarte finalement du principe général
de la loi qui
qui doit être reconnu au sein de la
société et puis reconnu donc par les
élus locaux les élus locaux ce sont les
élus qui portent bien le nom ils sont
élus et ils sont et ils sont prêts à
être contrôlés en tant que tel mais ils
ont
ils ont dans leurs mains un mandat
et ça finalement un moment donné on
s'écarte un peu aussi cet esprit là de
l'esprit de la liberté municipale
lorsque finalement quand vous allez
voler aller au bout de votre projet
finalement vous rencontrez un tas de
personnes qui vont intervenir sur
le processus
qui finalement semble avoir beaucoup
plus de droits sur le projet que
vous-même en tant que représentante de
de l'intérêt de l'intérêt général et
donc voilà il y a un problème quand même
structurel évidemment qui peut déborder
sur le sentiment que les citoyens ont
sur des choses qui sont quelquefois
relativement simple
la vie du starliser tout à l'heure sur
l'assainissement je vois la question 6
mois y compris sur ma commune sur le le
ruissellement l'eau risque d'aller
beaucoup plus vite que notre capacité
quelquefois à l'arrêté lorsqu'elle
lorsqu'elle ruisselle et évidemment
l'habitant qui la reçoit dans son
sous-sol ne comprend pas pourquoi nous
procrastinons c'est aussi
c'est aussi un exemple donc je pense
qu'il faut saluer cette cette
démarche qui consisterait à réinterroger
la nécessité de la loi c'est ce que vous
voulez inscrire également dans
l'engagement et vous voulez faire signer
aussi le gouvernement ce qui est une
bonne idée
effectivement bon tout le monde a sa
part dans dans l'inflation normative
mais
il va falloir quand même
arriver et aboutir à quelque chose et
quelquefois simplification
ça finit en complexité on le voit
sur le terrain et
il y a un mot qu'on n'utilise peu c'est
abrogation il y a peut-être des choses
qui pourraient disparaître et j'en viens
effectivement à cet exemple sur les
ressources humaines les ressources
humaines
le fait que les agents de la des
collectivités et des carrières et que
celle-ci puisse être
accompagnée
c'est indéniable le fait que une
collectivité est besoin d'agent
pour le projet du territoire pour mettre
pour faire mettre en place les services
municipaux c'est une réalité aussi mais
effectivement lorsque on voyait la
différence entre les côtes tout à
l'heure au niveau de leur taille la
façon dont ils ont enflé ça a été
rappelé
mais il y a le droit du travail
il y a le code général des collectivités
territoriales il y a la fonction
publique territoriale et cette
empilement à un moment donné quelquefois
contradictoires quelquefois évidemment à
l'échelle d'une commune rurale encore
plus
encore plus délicat
à appliquer parce que il faut passer par
le médecin du travail parce que il faut
la vie du comité technique paritaire
voilà alors moi je prononcerai
volontiers là on n'est pas là pour faire
la loi mais je sais pas si je le faisais
voté est-ce qu'on pourrait pas arrêter
avec le tableau des emplois voilà le
tableau des emplois tout le monde
connaît ici je pense mais
quand vous en êtes réduit dans un
conseil municipal ou finalement
vous avez 80% des délibérations de la
soirée qui ne sont là que pour
satisfaire la norme
décider de la création de trois postes à
3 grades différents pour le même besoin
de la collectivité pour être sûr qu'on
puisse dans les temps
satisfaire ce besoin c'est de bien
complètement incroyable évidemment il
faudra donc en défaire deux une fois
qu'on aura recruté la personne
correspondant au grade de l'une des
trois
délibération
sans rappeler que cette délibération
donc elle va être
elle va être photocopiée au temps de la
dématérialisation quand même le maire le
sait puisque ça se retrouve dans son
parapheur et que c'est le genre de
choses qui va signer plusieurs fois sans
compter évidemment tous les arrêtés qui
vont suivre
il y a un moment donné où sans
forcer la comparaison d'une collectivité
locale avec une entreprise
nous ne sommes ni plus ni moins des
employeurs au regard du droit du travail
essentiellement il faudrait revenir
à cet aspect potentiel en quoi ça nous
coûte a été rappelé par notre collègue
au milieu de son champ c'est quoi c'est
que
on passe plus de temps à répondre à
toutes ces questions de normes et on
passe moins de temps sur nos projets et
c'est nos projets qui construisent
l'avenir c'est nos projets qui font de
la commande publique pour faire
fonctionner aussi les entreprises et
avant qu'effectivement sur ce chant il y
ait une carotte qui finissent dans
l'assiette des enfants à la cantine
voyez bien que
sans compter évidemment que ça sort pas
comme ça d'un champ une carotte il
faudra aussi un travail préalable mais
finalement on va passer beaucoup plus de
temps
à tergiverser une fois de plus pour un
élu de la République qui est élu sur un
projet qui manifestement ensuite peut
aussi avoir des projets en cours de
mandat et des partager avec les
habitants et avec le conseil municipal
qui va valider quand même un certain
nombre d'étapes et bien il va y avoir
toute une série de de
d'instance ou d'associations
au projet qui vont à un moment donné
démunir ou freiner freiner véritablement
le projet
urbanisme c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un autre exemple que je voulais
donner je veux pas deuxième langue parce
qu'on a un timing très très correct très
serré sur la parole j'en dirai pas grand
chose c'est plutôt peut-être du point de
vue du demandeur on est
on est sur un dossier pour une
déclaration préalable de travaux qui est
passée de une à huit pages voilà en
quelques en quelques années c'est vrai
qu'il y a des pages où il y a presque
rien dessus mais voilà les gens sont
toujours étonnés quand ils arrivent
comme ça et puis que on leur présente le
dossier pour une clôture pour voilà
aujourd'hui on est dans le fond vert
peut-être que notre ministre en parlera
tout à l'heure sujet qui défend
évidemment ce sont des des
des apports en termes de subventions
pour les communes et au passage rappelé
qu'il existait une dotation de
subventions générale et qu'elle a été
morcelée en différentes choses qui sont
voilà on aligne les équations alors que
là pour l'occasion également sur les
dotations de l'État on pourra avoir une
seule dotation et puis en fonction du
projet rentré dans cette différenciation
au bon sens du terme
et c'est pas c'est pas toujours le cas
sur le sur le fond vert
on a un exemple s'il vous plaît mon
collègue Bertrange corne publié l'autre
jour sur son sur son fil Facebook
on demande un moment donné sur
sur les économies d'énergie qui peuvent
être réalisés
à l'occasion d'un changement
de l'éclairage public on demande
précisément
la le rapport en termes de lumens et
apparemment y compris même les
opérateurs qui étaient autour de lui et
qui avait pu faire des estimatifs au
début il était incapable de répondre à
la question donc là encore les Luc
locales il faut qu'il puisse s'inscrire
dans le projet et quand on va passer à
aux questions techniques c'est une autre
affaire mais être bloqué au moment
évidemment où est-ce qu'on nous le
demande sur le site que vous connaissez
pour certains qui s'appelle démarche
simplifiées voilà merci beaucoup
je conclus juste avec peut-être juste un
élément
donnez-nous confiance je pense que ça a
été rappelé par notre collègue et
président David Isnard donnez-nous
confiance et
effectivement
faites au-delà du cnen qui est une
instance que je connais bien puisque j'y
suis aussi au-delà du CNEM Créon la
proposition dont tu as parlé le
sénateur.tro tout à l'heure sur un
comité local avec le préfet créons des
lieux d'échanges de façon à ce que
l'univers de la réalité et le process
législatif se rencontrent beaucoup plus
pour que nous soyons plus efficaces
merci merci c'est une effectivement des
propositions du Sénat nous y reviendrons
une instance de concertation préfet élu
Christophe bouillon bonjour vous êtes
maire de Barentin vous présiez
l'association des petites villes de
France vous allez nous expliquer un peu
les résultats d'une consultation que
vous aviez vous-même mené auprès de vos
adhérents ma une petite ville et donner
quelques exemples concrets j'attire
votre attention sur le fait qu'il faut
respecter un timing très très court
trois quatre minutes je serai pas
désobligeant mais je suis obligé si tout
le monde parle trop nous n'aurons pas le
temps d'entendre tout le monde je me
tais à mon tour à vous merci d'avoir
merci à Françoise Gatel et puis à Rémi
pointeaux de nous permettre finalement
de porter témoignage dans le cadre de
ces états généraux de la simplification
donc il faut souhaiter qu'elle ne
boutisse pas en fin de parcours à une
création de norme mais plutôt de mode
d'emploi c'est ça dont nous avons je
crois besoin l'association Le Petit
villes de France fédère des territoires
entre 2500 et 25000 habitants c'est dire
que lorsque nous réalisons une enquête
flash pour solliciter la vie de nos élus
finalement on fait parler l'ensemble des
départements des territoires ruraux ou
urbains et ça m'étonnera personne ce que
nous disent nous élus à travers cette
enquête flash de rejoindre parfaitement
les constats que vous avez établi et qui
ont été rappelés tout à l'heure par Rémi
Cointreau auquel on pourrait aussi
associer le récent rapport du Conseil
national des violations des normes qui
convergent et tant mieux dans les
constats qui dit en effet que
concrètement pour l'ensemble des élus
c'est boulimie des normes c'est à la
fois lourd cher long et parfois
décourageant j'insiste sur ce point
parce qu'on voit aussi beaucoup de
collectivités qui finissent par
abandonner
la portée de projet et je crois que ça
c'est plutôt ça doit nous inquiéter on
pourrait se dire ne pas aller jusqu'au
bout des projets pourquoi pas mais en
même temps concrètement ça a des effets
à la fois en termes d'attractivité en
termes de dynamique économique à
l'échelle des territoires alors pour
tenir les engagements de temps je
voudrais citer trois exemples de prix
sur ma commune et une prix pour faire
plaisir à notre président du Sénat dans
les dans les Yvelines
deux exemples sur ma commune le premier
c'est pour souligner ce qui était dit
tout à l'heure par emipouattro en ce qui
concerne parfois les injonctions
contradictoires
on nous demande par exemple à travers le
décret tertiaire de veiller à une
meilleure isolation le bâtiment à
respecter en état en tout cas des
consommations moindres énergétiques et
en même temps il y a aussi la question
importante qui est celle de
l'accessibilité concrètement quand vous
avez par exemple à procéder à une
isolation thermique d'un bâtiment par
l'extérieur quand les bâtiments sont et
bien vous êtes confronté à cet enjeu qui
est celui de l'accessibilité pour
respecter un certain nombre de largeurs
deuxième exemple
assez simple
on a aujourd'hui c'est injonction en
termes d'économie par rapport à aux
ressources on parle beaucoup d'énergie
mais il faut parler aussi de l'eau quand
des collectivités aujourd'hui veulent
par exemple réduire les consommations
d'eau générée dans les écoles ou dans
d'autres bâtiments notamment des
bâtiments sportifs par exemple en
voulant utiliser les autres pluies ou
les eaux usées des du lave-main par
exemple après traitement elles ont soit
empêché par les normes c'est à dire
qu'on leur demande aux collectivités de
faire un effort important en termes
d'économie d'eau mais aujourd'hui c'est
une arme qui empêche d'aller plus loin
en la matière alors qu'on parle de
sobriété troisième et dernier exemple
prix dans les Yvelines dans la commune
de Villepreux c'est
administré par mon collègue
Jean-Baptiste à Monique
c'est l'histoire du poulailler mobile on
a aussi cette inflexion assez forte
aujourd'hui de favoriser les filières
courts de respecter les Pat des
programmes alimentaires territoriaux
c'est ce qu'il souhaite faire simplement
il est confronté à l'exercice qui a été
tout à l'heure dans le petit reportage
rappelé parfois on a le PLU qui percute
le PRI le PPRI sur des risques
inondations quand vous avez c'est cela
de survoit le territoire je rappelle
qu'il y a quand même plus de 400 000
cours d'eau en France c'est-à-dire que
beaucoup de territoires sont concernés
par cette cette exigence et ce risque il
se dit dans ce document qu'on peut
permettre de construire des équipements
en dur mais pas un poulailler qui est un
équipement peu considéré comme étant
éphémère il finit par trouver une
solution
dans la cuvette quelque part sauf qu'on
lui dit bien évidemment étant dans la
plaine de Versailles
qu'il ne faut pas que depuis Versailles
on puisse voir le poulailler
c'est une vraie question mais c'est une
question de norme c'est une question
dedans et dans la cuvette qu'est-ce
qu'il rencontre il rencontre à nouveau
le PPRI résultat des courses après trois
ans d'effort le poulailler mobile n'est
toujours pas installé je dis ça sans
doute avec le sourire mais des exemples
de cette nature il y en a beaucoup et
pour terminer je pense qu'il faut lier
et ça a été pointé dans son introduction
par Françoise Gatel la question de la
simplification avec la question la
judiciarisation parce que la vérité
aussi c'est que les élus se protègent et
la protection
amène aussi justement à vouloir bien
évidemment aller dans une dans un
phénomène de parapluie quelque part mais
en même temps et je voudrais rebondir
sur les propos de notre président David
Isnard il y a la question de la
différenciation il en a esquissé un
contour qui nous va quelque part mais je
pense que dans l'invitation qui est
faite récemment dans terme de réformes
institutionnelle le point de vue des
collectivités doit être celui qui doit
donner une définition de différenciation
qui empêche bien sûr la dérive qu'il
pointait par ailleurs qui est celle de
d'oublier aussi le rôle de l'État et
l'égalité aussi que l'on doit aux
collectivités dans ce domaine voilà je
serai pas plus long merci beaucoup
Christophe bouillon pour votre concision
aussi les exemples très concrets que
vous avez donné Marie-Claude Jarreau à
vos côtés maire de Montceau-les-Mines en
Saône-et-Loire quand on préparait votre
intervention vous me disiez il faut
trouver un juste milieu entre la jungle
des pourvu de toute règle de toutes
norme et un jardin à la française qui
empêcherait toute action locale des élus
locaux nous vous écoutons témoignage et
point de vue
bonjour à vous toutes et à vous toutes
en vous grades et qualités merci pour
cette belle initiative madame la
présidente de la délégation collectivité
territoriale je suis très honorée de
pouvoir témoigner devant vous alors je
vais aller vite
vous m'avez donné des des consignes je
vais essayer de les respecter
déjà
quatre phrases concernant cette le sujet
qui nous
occupe c'est sûr les normes nuisent à
l'attractivité de nos territoires
empêche que nous puissions travailler
sérieusement à l'attractivité de notre
étoile
parfois les normes nous démoralisent
nous désespèrent comme mes collègues
l'ont dit et empêche les élus locaux de
d'être optimiste et le président tout à
l'heure a parlé de des élus qui qui
perdent un peu espoir c'est une réalité
de territoire vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Pointreau c'est une réalité de
territoire que je constate en tant que
présidente des maires de Saône-et-Loire
la superposition des normes elle crée
des tunnels des complexités
incompréhensibles et puis je terminerai
ce propos liminaire en disant que les
normes créent des interactions avec les
autorités des concentrées qui sont des
interactions perdants perdants
crispation est de mauvaises interactions
je reparlerai des interactions tout à
l'heure alors
j'avais droit à cinq exemples je vais
aller vite 5 exemples premier exemple
rénover un complexe sportif c'est à dire
appliquer des normes dans le domaine
électrique dans le domaine sanitaire
dans le domaine de la transition
écologique et dans le domaine de l'accès
de l'accession handicapée
on nous demande pour l'accession
handicapée évidemment c'est normal qu'on
nous demande ça on nous demande que
c'est accession que le bâtiment soit
accessible partout le grand complexe
soit accessible partout alors qu'avant
il n'était accessible
nulle part il nous a fallu
casser les tribunes
toutes les tribus parce que accessible
par tout mettre deux ascenseurs alors
que nous avons dit que un seul ascenseur
suffisait on nous a obligé on nous a
obligé ce qui a créé un surcoût
financier très important nous n'avons
pas pour autant renoncer mais on peut
admettre que certains collègues auraient
certainement renoncer de garlas
l'électricité les normes changent
pratiquement tous les trois ans et on
met plus de trois ans pour pour rénover
un grand complexe sportif le confort
thermique des créditaires 40% d'économie
2030 2045 ans 2050 60
tout ça ça crée un effet multiplicateur
et ça et ça ça nuit à la qualité du
projet et ça peut faire renoncer au
projet de plus l'État la Région le
Département additionne des critères pour
être éligibles à la subvention et nous
ne remplissons pas toujours
tous les critères et philologie pour les
régions enfin je vous passe les termes
quelquefois incompréhensibles aussi donc
c'est un exemple de superposition des
normes on ne rentre presque jamais
jamais dans les dans on cause jamais
toutes les cases et là vous m'aviez
évoqué monsieur brivel la possibilité de
faire de parler de notre relation avec
l'État et là il faut une bonne relation
avec le sous-préfet ou avec le préfet et
ou avec le préfet pour que l'on puisse
cocher toutes les cases sinon on n'y
arrive pas on a cette superposition des
critères normatifs qui nous conduit à
quelquefois à un moment donné deuxième
exemple et nous en resterons un deuxième
exemple si vous voulez bien car je vous
repasserai la parole après je vous
promets mais si on veut un temps de
débattre
j'espère pouvoir installer faire vos
photosvoltaïques sur un terrain et sur
enfin sur une friche et sur un lac un
lac minier la pas de problème de Zana
mais le fond friche n'est pas ouvert
à cela parce que c'est pas une friche où
l'on va reconstruire une usine ou des
logements c'est simplement pour
conserver un patrimoine on restaure on
met en valeur un patrimoine industriel
aucun levier pour assurer la transition
de cette friche la norme pour le coup la
norme a oublié ce cas qui n'est pas un
carhar sur les territoires industriels
ou sur les territoires historiques
donc la norme a oublié la préservation
du patrimoine par contre et c'est là
toute l'absurdité si nous avions détruit
ce patrimoine on rentrerait dans le fond
friche
parce que on poursuivrait des objectifs
transition aménagement du territoire
alors que en préservant un patrimoine on
poursuit aussi ces mêmes objectifs
sur cette friche sur cette même friche
pour financer sa conservation je termine
je me dépêche
nous allons produire de l'électricité le
jour mais aujourd'hui à ce moment où je
vous parle la loi favorise un peu la
position prépondérante DDF et son
lobbying et
ralentit l'évolution des textes qui doit
permettre aux collectivité de revendre
de l'électricité pour financer les
investissements
si on a besoin de simplification là il
faut que l'on puisse à la fois produire
et revente comme on peut produire et
revendre alors cette cité par rapport au
jardin au collègue l'a dit à distance
des pommes de terre tout simplement ça
nous permettrait d'être plus efficace
dans notre production d'électricité qui
est souhaitée et notre autoconsommation
qui souhaitait par le gouvernement j'ai
encore trois exemples mais on va pas
avoir le temps mais on va mais vous
pourrez merci de votre attention désolé
madame Jarreau mais merci en tout cas de
ces deux exemples très concrets
mais la matinée est très chargée clair
demain que votre voisine juriste avocate
et rédactrice en chef de l'agit
actualité juridique des collectivités
territoriales avec vous c'est l'oeil
d'une praticienne du droit votre rôle
c'est justement d'expliquer de décrypter
la réglementation notamment aux élus
locaux quel œil vous portez sur ce
maquis normatif 4-5 minutes pas plus
s'il vous plaît j'étais en train de tout
couper alors merci Monsieur merci madame
la Présidente pour votre invitation j'ai
je coupe je coupe je coupe parce que il
y a déjà énormément de choses qui ont
été dites moi j'interviens ici à côté
des élus pour témoigner donc à mon tour
de l'inflation normative mais ma
pratique elle diffère quelques peu de
mes voisins moi j'ai pas les mains dans
le cambouis ou dans le poulailler mobile
je savais même pas que ça existait voilà
j'ai les mains dans le JO donc mon
travail consiste avec un certain nombre
de collègues des éditions Lefebvre
daloza a dépouillé le Journal officiel
chaque matin et oui j'ai mon stock de
doliprane chaque matin j'essaye de
suivre le rythme des textes publiés je
vous invite à lire le journal officiel
en fin d'année autour du 31 décembre
c'est la fête voilà Lefèvre dalhouse
donc Edith a un mensuel à destination
des joys de collectivités l'actualité
juridique des collectivités
territoriales et de nombreux codes que
vous connaissez on en a parlé de
certains le CGCT le code général des
collectivités territoriales le code de
l'urbanisme qui fait mal le code général
de la Fonction publique et comme il y a
rien de tel que l'image
dans le métro j'ai pas pu tous les
rapporter voilà ça c'est le poids des
normes expliquez-nous alors le premier
et le second
que vous voyez qui date de 82 vous
m'entend il date de 82 le code de
l'urbanisme il comptait 600 pages
magnifique un beau papier celui de 2022
toujours en papier mais en papier bible
cette fois-ci il en compte 3600
je voulais je voulais passerai le code
général des collectivités territoriales
de 1996 un peu plus gros déjà puisqu'on
avait compris que c'était difficile de
tout faire rentrer dans le petit format
et celui de 2023 voilà donc ça c'est
parlant je peux me cacher derrière comme
vous pouvez le voir
et donc pour filer la métaphore de la
maladie qui vous est cher
oui
ils sont plus grands et le papier le
papier est différent de mots
et il tenait dans la poche le but à
l'époque c'était le livre de poche c'est
loin d'être le livre de poche et les le
prix non plus le prix d'un livre de
poche alors claire DEC les raisons de
cette inflation normative je voulais
juste vous dire
donc les codes sont aujourd'hui obèses
voilà vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous
avez utilisé ce terme alors bien sûr
c'est un peu facile aussi c'est l'image
il y a d'autres choses le sujet il est
plus subtil il n'empêche je reviens
toujours à Victor Hugo parce qu'on a
beaucoup cité mais moi j'aime beaucoup
Victor Hugo la forme c'est le fond qui
remonte à la surface et donc il faut
toujours quand même s'arrêter à ces
images là je vais faire hyper court
puisque les sujets ont été abordés de
façon très intelligente jusqu'à
maintenant et je renvoie aux coloc qui a
eu lieu le 14 octobre dernier sur la
simplification normative qui a été
organisée par le Conseil d'État et le
CNE et qui est librement accessible sur
le site du Conseil d'État sous la forme
de podcast aussi si vous voulez en
ressortir plus intelligent sur ce sujet
mais je vous invite à y aller
donc trones et elles sont complexes je
vais aller hyper vite j'ai tout coupé
d'abord on en a parlé les normes
répondent à des besoins légitimes à une
société qui se complexifie je prendrais
juste l'exemple de l'intelligence
artificielle on a parlé de
l'environnement effectivement des
injonctions contradictoires mais on a
aussi une journée une société qui
s'interne nationalise et qui tout
simplement techniquement de plus en plus
compliqué il est énorme ne sont que le
reflet de la société et je dirais c'est
plutôt bien d'ailleurs on en a parlé la
complexité c'est pas forcément un mal
c'est effectivement sans doute la
complication qu'on est vous avez parlé
de l'urgence
la loi magique qui répond à une émotion
on en parle souvent en droit pénal
c'est souvent dans ce cas là mais ça
peut être le cas dans d'autres
situations La Faute-sur-Mer on peut
parler de d'autres situations et la
question on agit dans l'urgence on prend
un test on vote une loi en réponse en
fait à une émotion à une émotion
générale et on se pose pas la question
de l'arsenal législatif préexiste et ça
c'est un vrai problème puisqu'on empile
au lieu de se poser et de réfléchir et
quand on rédige dans l'urgence on rédige
mal quand on fait vite les choses on
fait mal globalement
nous on le voit puisque nous on
consolide nos codes donc on voit quand
c'est plutôt bien fait ou quand c'est
plutôt mal fait
de même quand on simplifie on
complexifie c'est un peu les Shadoks
pourquoi faire simple quand on peut
faire compliqué le Conseil d'État
relevait dans son étude annuel en 2016
qui avait 130 textes de simplification
qui avait été adopté en dix ans si ça
avait été totalement efficace on serait
pas réuni aujourd'hui donc je vous
donnerai juste un exemple de
simplification contre-productif de ces
dernières années qui est le silence veut
acceptation personne n'en a parlé si moi
ça m'avait frappé le silence va
acceptation ou plutôt le silence vos
refus voilà pour moi c'est vraiment ce
sont les Shadoks là c'est vraiment
kafkaïen
puis même la mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui
est-ce que quelqu'un est capable de
parler du silence doit acceptation de
façon concrète voilà juste c'est très
intéressant moi je suis souscrit
quand il y a eu le parce que c'était
parti d'un vrai très beau travail de
Thierry Brandon etc demandée par
François Hollande et à la fin moi je
l'ai vécu dans ma commune il y a eu
ensuite la machine la Matrix qui arrive
là
Léviathan le nombre de dérogations et de
ce qui signifie que pour savoir si vous
devez répondre ou pas il fallait voir
recruter quelqu'un dans ma commune
donc on a décidé de répondre à tout le
monde ce qu'on faisait déjà avant voilà
donc c'est typiquement c'est un
excellent exemple de l'absurdité
ubuesque de tout cela le gouvernement
avait envisagé à l'époque de créer une
un logiciel une petite une application
sur laquelle en fait les citoyens
pouvaient répondre un peu épouser la
question est-ce que ça c'est un silence
c'est un cas de silence va acceptation
ils ont dû abandonner au bout de six
mois ce qui était impossible de dresser
la liste voilà on y arrive pas
j'ai vacurai le droit européen mais ça
ça mérite qu'on s'y attarde oui car on
se contente pas de transcrire vous
disiez madame Berthel mais en
surtranscrit en France
en soi c'est pas forcément un mal on
adapte la norme à des exigences à des
nécessités nationales mais ça participe
à la réglementation le comble étant
quand on adopte des lois pour lutter
contre la surtransposition donc là c'est
ça donne le vertige je donnerai un autre
exemple le code général de la Fonction
publique le de codification a été menée
de façon excellente l'objectif poursuivi
il était très
il était très honorable il se trouve que
au fur et à mesure du moment de de
l'utilisation qu'il y a entre un an on
se rend compte qu'il y a des petites
subtilités d'un point de vue pratique
notamment par exemple la journée du
premier mai je sais que beaucoup en ont
parlé puisque le CGFP renvoie au code du
travail dorénavant pour rémuner les
rémunérer les agents publics qui
travaillent le 1er mai qui n'était pas
le cas auparavant donc un petit
complexité voilà petite chose strap
petite surprise en fait
donc je dirais trop de normes des normes
complexes je citerai des exemples de
gros gros gros textes 177 articles pour
la loi alur 234 pour la loi Elan et 271
articles pour la loi 3DS et beaucoup de
décrets d'applications en cascade et pas
forcément pris dans les délais
d'ailleurs mais pour ça
mais on en a pas parlé il faut qu'on
parle aussi de l'instabilité de la norme
il me semble que quand le code de la
commande publique a été a été est entré
en vigueur avant même d'ailleurs qu'il
entre en veillant il y avait déjà des
textes qui étaient pris pour modifier le
futur code de la commande publique en
fait on passe notre temps à courir après
après une norme qui soit relativement
stable ça peut décourager donc
aujourd'hui le risque c'est celui d'une
norme qui est peu intelligible on a
parlé mais qui est difficilement
accessible des textes qui procèdent par
envoi j'en ai parlé avec le CGFP le CGCT
une mise en oeuvre différée
et c'est très compliqué on peut
l'entendre pour ceux qui ne sont pas
experts mais moi j'interviens comme
juriste aussi puisque nous codiste nous
sommes juristes
moi sincèrement je frémis des froid
quand je dois ouvrir le code général des
impôts donc même pour des gens qui
peuvent se déclarer experts aujourd'hui
le droit est très complexe donc très
bien
je conclus un petit Bose conclusion je
conclus sur un exemple qui peut paraître
caricatural mais je trouve qu'il est
très parlant c'est un arrêt rendu par la
Cour administrative d'appel de Douai en
janvier ou une secrétaire de mairie
avait falsifié la signature du maire sur
des documents afin d'obtenir le
versement d'heure supplémentaires
qu'elle n'avait pas à réaliser
et pour contester la sanction qui lui
était infligée elle arguait de son
faible niveau de qualification alors
bien sûr
on était en face de la mauvaise foi la
plus pure puisque si elle avait usurpé
la signature de son maire qu'elle
n'avait pas réalisé ses heures
supplémentaires on était en face d'une
fraude mais je trouve que c'est quand
même assez parlant puisqu'elle a quand
même estimé que elle n'était pas assez
formée qu'elle ne connaissait pas la loi
et ça il faut l'entendre je pense dans
la pratique quotidienne
mais d'ailleurs je ne s'en avais parlé
monsieur le snarule n'est censé ignorer
la loi mais elle est parfois très
difficile à connaître quant à la
maîtriser je vous laisse je vous laisse
juge merci beaucoup pour votre
intervention
nous avons
cinq à dix minutes maximum de débat avec
vous si des personnes dans la salle ont
envie de témoigner de commenter de
réagir vous prenez la parole vous me
faites signe vous levez la main vous
vous présentez s'il vous plaît nom
prénom fonction et vous posez vous
faites une intervention s'il vous plaît
très courte monsieur
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que ça devient quand même
une vraie problématique c'est à dire que
faut se dépêcher d'ailleurs on voit que
tous les marchés publics les entreprises
même sont sollicités au même moment dans
les mandats parce que il faut se
dépêcher parce que sinon on n'aura pas
le temps en fait de de livrer le projet
avant la fin du mandat et donc on c'est
une forme de stérilisation aussi d'un
certain nombre de projets qu'on sait
très bien ne pas pouvoir réaliser dans
les délais impartis et je pense que
c'est un vrai handicap pour les communes
merci pour ce témoignage une des façons
peut-être de d'accélérer de concilier ce
temps législatif réglementaire et ce
temps politique c'est peut-être aussi
la capacité à adapter l'application de
la norme dans les témoignages que qu'on
a entendu ce matin ça n'a pas été
vraiment évoqué ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est si les uns les autres vous
êtes parvenu avec le préfet l'architecte
des bâtiments de France la DREAL a
adapté
la norme la règle aux spécificités de
votre territoire madame Jarreau est-ce
que par exemple vous avez réussi à
trouver un modus opérandi
excusez-moi je crois que je l'avais mis
tout dépend de la personnalité du préfet
avec lequel on travaille et de et de sa
volonté de nous accompagner bon moi j'ai
eu la chance depuis que je suis maire
d'avoir des préfets qui nous ont qui
m'ont toujours accompagné néanmoins
néanmoins malgré cela quelquefois nous
n'arrivons pas à démarrer les projets ou
à faire en sorte que les projets soient
suivis je donnais un exemple une chose
que je n'ai jamais réussi à faire à ce
jour ça fait 8 ans 8 ans que je suis
mère l'entretien des perrets
c'est impossible
impossible de d'avoir un entretien
régulier des paires tout simplement
parce qu'il y a des conventions de
superposition VNF
état enfin VFC l'État et puis et puis et
puis
des PCI on se rejette la responsabilité
des choses qu'on ne peut pas faire même
en interpellant même en interpellant le
préfet le préfet il a intervient pour
nous donner pour dire alors bon je ne
dirai rien sur ce sujet on va faire
comme ça on va donner l'autorisation
malgré le fait que vous n'ayez pas vous
n'ayez pas respecté toutes les
procédures mais il faut avoir un préfet
considère c'est toujours dans le cas
d'une relation
qu'il ne soit pas frileux sur le risque
de contentieux si il vous aide à adapter
le règlement je me permets juste de dire
là-dessus parce que c'est essentiel ce
qui manque c'est enfin notre réflexion
doit aussi concerner la déconcentration
des services de l'État et c'est
fondamental parce que
aujourd'hui le préfet ne peut pas être
le juge de paix qu'il devrait être
et même la notion de dire est-ce qu'on
peut adapter la norme au terrain moi
j'aurais fi ça une norme si elle doit
être modifiée par rapport à un projet
c'est qu'il y a un problème une norme
par définition face à la base du droit
quoi c'est à dire que cette norme en
fait cette modalité est devenue une
finalité c'est-à-dire que la norme est
devenue une finalité et donc c'est que
ça ne fonctionne pas et alors si pour
aller vite on pourrait dire il pourrait
y avoir une instance de d'arbitrage bon
au sens premier du terme et que ce
serait le préfet sauf qu'aujourd'hui
dans la réalité c'est pas adapté la
norme c'est que les normes se contredit
le préfet n'a pas d'autorité sur un DDTM
sauf exception et encore moins surréal
et on le voit très bien sur ce qui était
évoqué tout à l'heure sur les eaux les
gémapis et ce que ce que vous évoquez
c'est à dire que moi je l'ai vécu des
bassins des ouvrages de protection des
populations qui sont soutenus par les
préfets les sous préfets les délétés ou
des DTM selon le coin et qui sont
plantés par la Dréal
et chacun dans sa norme donc
on est au coeur du sujet alors c'est
peut-être pour ça monsieur Lisnard que
vous demandez au nom de la MF le
transfert d'un pouvoir réglementaire à
l'échelon local comment ça se passerait
ça c'est brièvement
c'est que en revienne à des grandes
dispositions dans le droit public et des
grandes lois qui fixent des objectifs
avec des évaluations des clauses de
rendez-vous etc et qu'ensuite et donc la
loi serait la même pour tout le monde
moi je suis attaché à cela mais
qu'ensuite la mise en oeuvre de la loi
dépend d'un pouvoir réglementaire qui
serait transféré aux collectivités selon
le type de loi d'objectif c'est un autre
débat ensuite au cas par cas et que le
temps ensuite contrôler vérifie et ça
changerait tout parce que dans le
conformisme que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est lorsque vous n'êtes pas
dans la dans le dans l'exigence du
praticien
vous vous
ne pouvez produire que que des textes
qui seront forcément déconnectés de la
réalité des objectifs c'est obligatoire
c'est comme un médecin qui voit jamais
un malade quoi c'est pas c'est pas
terrible effectivement madame Gatel et
ensuite je prends un témoignage dans la
salle
merci beaucoup cette intervention qui
montre vous l'avez dit Madame la
complexité des choses et que je pense
que si nous identifions clairement les
symptômes du mal qui nous ronge et nous
connaissons un peu les remèdes ils sont
multiples et ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui doit aller de père avec une
évaluation systémique de ce qu'il faut
de ce qu'il faut mettre en avant on a
parlé un peu de différenciation on a
aussi beaucoup dit et David Lisnard
vient de leur dire et beaucoup d'entre
vous on doit élaborer des lois qui
permettent des possibles c'est-à-dire
des adaptations dans l'unité de la
République et non pas des lois qui
interdisent ou obligent et enfin je
regarde mes collègues
sénateurs et notamment Agnès canaillé
qui avait ericaouche au nom de la
négation collectivité on produit un
remarquable
un remarquable travail sur alors qui
s'appelle le Sénat est sérieux mais peut
être drôle s'interpelle mieux
donc ils ont appelé le rapport à la
recherche de l'État dans les territoires
effectivement nous avons une vraie
difficulté de déficit de
l'accompagnement de l'État pour aider
les collectivités à mettre en oeuvre les
choses on peut parler d'usage
aujourd'hui il y a une circulaire du
préfet qui vous dit voilà alors le zan
c'est ça je parle pas des communes où la
secrétaire de mairie est là deux jours
et demi par semaine voilà et donc on met
une angoisse folle sur les une pression
folle sur les mains alors que je pense
que les préfets les devraient être
proactif venir expliquer la loi aux élus
et accompagner les élus dans la
réalisation donc quand on parle d'un
changement de culture c'est ça mais il
faut vraiment qu'on muscle aussi les
services déconcentrés de l'État et
l'action pédagogique l'action
pédagogique et qu'on est un préfet qui
est vraiment de l'autorité c'est-à-dire
quand vous êtes mains et vous racontez
vos histoires vous
partez sur un parcours du combattant qui
fait que vous allez voir ladreal ensuite
vous allez voir la BF ensuite vous allez
voir la DDTM donc les portes se ferment
au fur et à mesure derrière vous et
parfois vous avez un sous-préfet qui
peut vous dire j'aimerais beaucoup dire
à l'agréable ce film mais je ne peux pas
parce que je n'ai pas autorité sur lui
ce qui veut dire que le préfet doit
incarner l'État et permettre qu'on parle
d'une seule voie la simplification mais
aussi là merci deux petites
interventions Monsieur Madame dans le
fond monsieur si vous pouvez
la Marne donc juste vous souhaitiez deux
petits exemples donc je rejoins tout à
fait les propos qui ont été présentés
jusqu'à présent et ce que je regrette
c'est un petit peu de constater le
manque de bon sens dans la loi par deux
exemples la mobilité aujourd'hui sur mon
territoire donc centre bourg isolé j'ai
souhaité mettre une navette intra-muros
en place déjà pour des enclavés les
quartiers de mon centre ville et une
navette extra murose pour faire en sorte
que les petits villages environnants
puissent revenir sur le centre bois donc
la loi de retrait nous a demandé de
porter compétences qui a été donné dans
un premier temps à la région la région
nous a dit est-ce que l'intercommunalité
souhaite récupérer cette compétence
l'intercommunalité à récupérer la
compétence mais ne souhaite pas financer
les projets des communes donc j'ai
sollicité effectivement
l'intercommunalité en disant de quelle
manière est-ce que la ville de Cézanne
peut financer intégralement son projet
sans demander un sous à
l'intercommunalité et là vite juridique
on m'explique ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas votre compétence vous ne
pouvez pas agir premier exemple deuxième
exemple donc nous sommes très attachés à
notre patrimoine dans notre commune
petite cité de caractères on a un
certain nombre de bâtiments qui sont en
péril et à ce titre donc moi j'ai des
propriétaires privés qui me disent
écoutez il y a pas de souci ce bâtiment
on le connaît ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
en ruine si vous indiquez aux
propriétaires que effectivement il est
en péril je m'engage à le racheter à la
réhabilité c'est un contrat moral on
peut le signer etc j'ai interpellé à ce
sujet le ministère avec un courrier qui
avait été porté par le député Charles de
Courson pour savoir comment est-ce
qu'une commune pouvait récupérer
un immeuble en péril si il n'avait pas
de projet derrière et bien j'attends
encore la réponse puisqu'il y invite
juridique donc voilà simplement deux
exemples pour vous dire qu'on multiplie
la norme on multiplie les règles par
contre quand on a des cas concrets et
qu'on cherche des solutions on n'a pas
les réponses donc faudra peut-être
effectivement se poser les bonnes
questions alors on verra si le Sénat
dans ses propositions permettra de
régler ce genre de choses on n'y arrive
presque une intervention dans le fond et
une très très courte devant vous je vais
faire court
d'une collectivité périurbaine et
néanmoins rurale au sud je représente
aujourd'hui le maire de Grosset auproux
qui est souffrante je vois dans la
superposition des normes une sorte de
différentes couches d'enrobées qu'on
voit sur nos voiries dans les
collectivités on superpose on superpose
on enrobe en robe et un jour ça casse et
actuellement j'ai plein de buses
beaucoup de buses en galva qui casse et
il faut tout refaire et ça coûte
extrêmement cher j'ai l'impression que
notre Parlement il est un petit peu dans
cette situation là j'ai lu tout le
rapport ce matin dans l'avion en
arrivant à Paris et je fais les sites
toute cette délégation qui pour un
travail extraordinaire avec beaucoup de
avec beaucoup de choses innovantes je
regrette que cet instance de dialogue
qui avait été créé et accepté par le
Sénat a été ensuite été ensuite être
retour par l'Assemblée nationale c'est
dommage mais je vois dans ce rapport
beaucoup de choses sur la formation La
formation des hauts fonctionnaires que
je trouve très très bien cependant je
trouve qu'on s'éloigne et comme le
Parlement actuellement je trouve qu'on
s'éloigne des réalités de terrain je
rejoins je rejoins là beaucoup Monsieur
Lisnard sur deuxième point je pense que
sur nos instances notamment sur le cnen
et sur ces instances locales il faut
intégrer des élus locaux et il faut il
faut intégrer les fonctionnaires
territoriaux je vois pas beaucoup de DGS
dans cette salle je vois beaucoup sans
doute d'étudiants ou fonctionnaires ou
de haut fonctionnaires et des élus
quelques élus peut-être moins mais pas
de fonctionnaires locaux et je pense que
des élus locaux et des fonctionnaires
locaux méritent d'être aussi dans ces
instances là merci je pense que votre
appel est va être pris en compte par le
Sénat madame vous pouvez appuyer sur le
bouton rouge devant vous et vous
présenter s'il vous plaît merci
bonjour Esther Bayol je suis consultante
pour les collectivités et je voulais
simplement remonter un exemple qui va
dans le sens de ce que vous disiez
madame Gatel sur l'importance des
services des concentrés la préfecture
enfin la DDTM des Landes par exemple
c'est doté de deux juristes qui sont
chargés d'accompagner les communes et
les collectivités sur le développement
de projet photovoltaïques parce que il y
a un vrai volontarisme et donc en amont
de la loi d'accélération des
renouvelables qui prévoit des
dérogations pour la loi littorale la il
y a eu plusieurs projets qui ont été
soumis à ce guichet unique et qui ont
permis d'obtenir des dérogations à la
continuation de l'urbanisme qui est
prévue dans la loi littorale et qui a
permis le développement de projet par
exemple sur des sites dégradés et on
voit que les arguments et la le guichet
unique a permis aussi de d'améliorer les
projets en faisant en sorte qu'il soit
réversibles par exemple et c'est un
voilà c'est un exemple de d'une de
service déconcentrés qui ont eu un voilà
une démarche volontariste et qui a mené
avec succès à de nouveaux projets locaux
en dehors des normes actuelles merci
pour votre témoignage toute dernière
intervention monsieur et nous passons à
la deuxième table ronde
merci Pierre Grosjean donc maire d'une
commune de 1700 habitants dans le Cher
donc comme une nouvelle moi je voudrais
juste témoigner vous vous avez vraiment
enfin c'est formidable de participer à
cette réunion quand on est un convaincu
comme moi de du besoin de simplifier par
contre on passera pas par les préfets
par les ABS moi je vais vous témoigner
d'une chose on a depuis plusieurs
préfets successifs préfaient-elles
préfet des gens dans le Cher qui
viennent à la rencontre sur le terrain
il y a pas de souci on a une ABS qui
vient quand elle est avec nous sur un
bâtiment quand le préfet est avec nous
pour modifier le cheminement d'un d'un
chemin rural dans dans une zone
d'activité le bon sens prend le dessus
mais lorsque ces personnes rentrent dans
leur château avec leurs services avec
toute cette inertie administrative qui
elle est en place les préfets changent
tous les deux ans mais l'administration
local reste en place et bien ils en
reviennent malheureusement au texte et
au texte seulement vous pouvez avoir une
ABS et je fais un cas très simple qui
d'embourge va vous dire cette cheminée
là qui a été mal refaite avec du ciment
qui n'est plus en brique et qui penche
on la démonte elle sert plus à rien
puisqu'on a pas le droit de faire de feu
dans dans les on a plus le droit de
faire de feu de bois dans nos dans nos
villes et puis quand elle revient et
vous avez deux jours après un mail qui
vous dit qu'il faut la remonter à
l'identique historique comme la cheminée
comme elle était avant voilà donc je
pense que demander au préfet de se
mettre en risque peut-être mais ça
suffit pas il faut pousser très fort
l'administration en acier qui régit un
petit peu toute la mise en application
de ces normes je vais pas m'apesantir
sur le constat chacun me connaît
et les formules les plus diverses
permettent d'en rendre compte
il y a
la vision historique qui consiste à
rappeler que du temps des Grecs qu'on
expliquait que nul n'était censé ignorer
la loi puisque elle figurait sur les
murs de l'Agora et le fait de s'amuser à
mesurer la taille du bâtiment qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui pour que la somme
des normes françaises européenne
puissent tenir dans un endroit où on
pourrait le voir et ensuite le lire ce
qui relèverait évidemment de
l'impossibilité pour une seule journée
et une seule personne
quel que soit la taille de ce qui serait
réalisé il y a la manière
comparative de le faire il y a le fait
d'en évaluer le coût peu importe
aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on a
globalement un code général
des collectivités territoriales qui a
très peu de volume je sais pas si c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est amusé à présenter
les codes qui sont peut-être avec les
éditeurs les seuls vrais gagnants de
cette inflation normative d'une manière
objective
et nous avons dépassé le million de mots
2 milliards d'euros c'est l'estimation
globalement de l'inflation normative sur
les cinq dernières années calculées par
la DGCL et avec une règle c'est que plus
vous êtes petit
plus vous avez de mal à suivre cette
inflation normative et donc par
conséquent on crée en particulier pour
les collectivités les plus petites de ce
pays mais pour un certain nombre
d'acteurs de petites tailles une sorte
de dégradation de leur capacité à agir
ou de leur compétitivité la
simplification est donc à la fois un
combat essentiel
pour que la puissance publique préserve
une capacité à agir et que son action
est du sens
et dans le même temps elle est un
impératif au vu des bouleversements
profonds économiques géopolitique
écologique bien sûr que nous traversons
il est d'usage pour chaque problème de
se demander qui en est le responsable je
veux dire que l'inflation des normes à
plusieurs paires
et que dans ce domaine
nous avons
une difficulté qui est devenue
systémique dans lequel il serait trop
simple d'aller identifier un responsable
et de considérer qu'en se débarrassant
de ce responsable on se débarrasserait
du problème je veux saluer la qualité du
rapport de Françoise Gatel et de Rémi
Pointreau du mois de janvier qui montre
que tous les acteurs alimentent cette
fabrique de la norme que le législateur
n'est pas en reste
et que parfois cette
multiplication des normes elle peut
répondre à un objectif légitime de
différenciation
pour tenir compte des réalités mais
parfois sous couvert de différenciation
on finit par les produire de la norme
qui ajoute de la complexité de manière
très forte
depuis 2017
le président de la République a souhaité
que il y ait une lutte contre le pot
excessif de la norme avec un engagement
qui avait été valorisé qui était le deux
pour un du Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe en juillet 2017 à chaque fois
qu'il y a un nouveau texte il faut en
supprimer deux
il y a eu des réussites
avec un nombre de décret autonomes qui a
été divisé par 10
il y a eu une diminution objective du
nombre de circulaire qui est aussi en
baissé pendant la période et il y a les
promesses de la loi 3DS qui ouvrent dans
un certain nombre de champs des
perspectives réelles
pour avancer mais ça c'est la moitié
pleine du verre
ou plus exactement la moitié vide qu'on
s'efforce de ne pas remplir pour ne pas
ajouter de la normale
il faut bien concevoir qu'à côté de ça
non seulement beaucoup restent à faire
aussi bien en matière de flux mais
surtout en matière de gisement de
simplification et de stock Achille
rapport sur les normes applicable aux
collectivités territoriales je cite face
à l'addiction aux ondes une thérapie de
choc
c'était le 26 janvier dernier et vous en
avez largement débattu ce matin au fond
c'est aussi le fruit d'un important
travail de concertation une manière
d'ailleurs de j'allais dire de
travailler de la délégation
l'objectif
est simple
proposer des mesures concrètes et
j'insiste sur le mot concret et je sais
que le président de la commission des
lois ainsi sur cette dimension concrète
en vue de limiter cette inflation
normative et freinée on en parle depuis
longtemps j'ai appartenu à deux
gouvernements qui s'était engagé à un
moratoire mais sans doute la définition
du mot moratoire
était quelque peu différente de celle
que l'Académie en donne parce que
derrière le moratoire il y en avait
toujours plus
et j'assume
en effet
il n'est pas la déplacement que je fais
que j'allais dire que nous faisons
ensemble parfois chers président de la
MF où nous nous rencontrons où les élus
locaux ne nous parlent pas de ce carcan
normatif
je pense au droit de l'urbanisme
Christophe bichut la cité mais
madame demain que vous aviez un très bel
empilement et sans doute par pudeur vous
me l'avez retirez mais je dois dire que
si je prends le seul code de l'urbanisme
le nombre de mots en disant
a augmenté de 40% dans le code de
l'urbanisme aujourd'hui la complexité du
droit est telle que la plupart des mères
sont obligés de faire appel à des
cabinets extérieurs pour rédiger leur
document d'urbanisme
et ce d'ailleurs sous les injonctions
des services de l'État ils ont perdu le
pouvoir d'agir et c'est pour moi une
vraie préoccupation parce que
pardonnez-moi je le dis devant un membre
éminent du Conseil d'État le président
adjoint de la section de
l'administration car en plus une
expérience d'élus entre l'époque où nous
étions ensemble élus
et aujourd'hui cette complexité là rend
quasiment impossible à pouvoir pourtant
fondamental qui nous a été donné par les
textes portant décentralisation
c'est-à-dire de pouvoir d'agir de
rédiger bien sûr avec le soutien dans un
dialogue avec les services de l'État
avec les autres collectivités
territoriales mais c'est un vrai sujet
et je dois vous dire puisque nous avons
mis en place un groupe de travail pour
travailler sur décentralisation
déconcentration et différenciation que
au-delà du premier sujet cher monsieur
le rapporteur de ce groupe de travail
qui est en face de moi monsieur buffet
et une des rapporteurs qui nous
accompagnaient il y a bien sûr le sujet
d'autonomie fiscal et financière mais
pardonnez-moi de le dire il faut
retrouver une capacité à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions et de
retrouver quelque part cette capacité à
agir
je ne doute pas
que les interventions des représentants
de l'Association des maires de France
marie-claujaro que je vois avec plaisir
ici le maire de Montceau-les-Mines mais
je doute pas mais presque voisin le
maire des Molières qui Elvis président
de l'association
aussi
des mers ruraux et je ne doute pas
Christophe bouillon l'a dit tout à
l'heure alors sous le regard visé la
rédactrice en chef d'actualité juridique
des collectivités territoriales je
voudrais vraiment qu'on puisse aboutir à
quelque chose de concret et qu'on passe
du colloque de la réunion du rapport à
la mise en œuvre concrète
le coût pour les collectivités c'est
plus de 2 milliards et demi d'euros
c'est des chiffres qui se recoupent
entre la Commission nationale
d'évaluation des normes et
la direction des collectivités
territoriales
[Musique]